in today's video we're going to be
focusing on the three macro triangles by
Bitcoin that we see recurring over time
and we can better understand what lies
ahead in the future for Bitcoin going
forward based on these historically
recurring Tendencies with history
already repeating because we've seen
another breakout on the three macro
triangles as in the past we're already
seeing a breakout even now so subscribe
to the channel for more videos like this
in the future like the video if you
enjoy videos like this going forward and
let's dive right into it
so three macro triangles very simple a
macro downtrend tends to be broken which
enables a new macro uptrend going into
the harving but particularly importantly
so rallying in a parabolic fashion after
the harving and we see that across time
macro downtrend breakout you can see a
breakout into the Haring event here we
saw a deeper retracement but parabolic
price action to new alltime highs after
the Haring event and here once again the
macro downtrend has broke we are in a
new macro uptrend reaccumulation period
here break out going into the harving
event and we'll probably also see
parabolic price action to new alltime
highs after the Haring event and this is
something I've been talking about for
the past year going back to June
2022 the three macro triangle theory is
something I've been talking about for a
while now and whenever we see price
break down from a descending triangle we
tend to see an acceleration phase to the
bare Market bottom you see that across
cycles and we saw that also in June
2022 and ultimately you you Tred to form
a generational bottom at these bare
Market Bottoms in this acceleration
phase and in October I spoke about how
we were in a final bottoming out phase
after that downtrend
acceleration in this tweet this is
downtrend acceleration into capitulation
then we see see the final generational
bottom here and then in November mid
November we've already experienced a
large part of its downtrend acceleration
phase and we're searching for a bare
Market bottom around 16600 so we only
went down an additional $11,000 to find
that bare Market bottom and in the
premium newsletter at the time I shared
how we tend to see either 50% downside
after a breakdown from the descending
triangle or
65% downside so we essentially came up
with a range of anything from 12K to 17K
being that bare Market bottom region and
the thing about that is we've before
seen a breakdown 65% towards the
downside we before saw a 50% downside
but we also mentioned how price tends to
break out a year before the Haring it
tends to break its macro downtrend a
year before the Haring or also in this
cycle a year before the harving is when
we tend to break beyond the macro
downtrend and a year before the Haring
is indeed where we broke out also before
the Haring event we bottomed out at that
15500 region turned towards the upside
entered or at least entered the pre-
breakout breakout phase preceding the
upward acceleration phase and we're in
the upward acceleration phase as we
speak so what can be next for Bitcoin
well we know that if we look at the preh
Haring period 2016 for instance after
the breakout from the macro downtrend we
entered a reaccumulation period and then
a preh Haring retrace period after we
broke out from that reaccumulation
period here we saw a breakout and then a
multimon pullback But ultimately after
the harving everything was fine rallying
to new alltime highs in a parabolic
fashion every single time so I think
it's very simple to answer the question
of what happens after the harving post
harving parabolic price action to new
alltime highs 200 days after the harving
or so is when we see new alltime highs
can we get there sooner it would go
against the grain of history but
anything is possible especially with the
20124 ETF Catalyst and harving event
being those two major cat IST that could
impact price action but the thing about
that is we need to also focus
on this descending triangle breakdown
point when we break down be below from
this triangle we turn it into resistance
sometimes and then we drop to the bare
Market bottom then you can see in 2016 a
re accumulation formed below this
resistance we broke beyond it and the
preing retrace saw price retest this as
a support so this was a support back
here turned into a resistance acted as
resistance again but weakening
resistance because it didn't reject
price too much in in fact it it forced
price into reaccumulation here and then
retesting this as a new support once
again so basically the story is from
support to resistance to to resistance
still and then new
support before rallying to new alltime
highs and you can see that this pattern
repeats right over here we had this as a
support broke beyond it quite
comfortably without having to
reaccumulate at all but then retrac into
this level to retest it as a support in
a picture perfect manner with still lots
of downside volatility below here but
nonetheless rallying into a new post
Haring parabolic rally and right here
this was a support which we lost back
here into the bare Market bottom and you
can see how right over here we were
resisting price quite a bit for a few
months a bit lower than this resistance
this level right over here so re
accumulating below here a little bit in
a very similar fashion to what we saw in
2016 and then you can see that we've
broken out Beyond here and maybe it's
time slowly but surely for price to mean
revert back into that level like we
saw in the past back into that level
once again so it's going to be either
before the harving or around the harving
event so in 2016 it was around the
harving event where we Revisited this
level here we Revisited it just before
the harving event and so we should
probably keep in mind that we could
revisit this level around the harving
event or just before it after we over
extend sufficiently and drop back into
this level right over here so this level
is approximately
$33,000 right over here so we can see
that the top of this reaccumulation
phase right this reaccumulation phase
the top of this the Range High was 31k
and we can see that this resistance
right over here is 33k so the people who
are thinking about longing at 31k for a
retest of that Range High Resistance
they might get front run because of this
level right over here 33k being that
really important generational support so
that could potentially be one of the
lower targets for a potential retrace
but at the same time you have to also
factor in that right over here we saw a
retrace into this level and even below
it in a volatile fashion of course there
was a catalyst that helped with that but
right over here we got a picture perfect
3 retest instead so if we see a picture
perfect retest like in 2016 then 33k
would be the bottom for a retrace in the
pre harving period or around the harving
period but if we were to see some sort
of downside deviation below
33k around that time that would be the
ultimate bargain buying opportunity for
Bitcoin one of the last fantastic
retraces and moments for a discount for
Bitcoin anything below 33k would be
absolute bargain buying
territory so 33k could be that level for
Bitcoin just before the Haring or around
the Haring event which also means that
maybe that preh Haring retrace that
tends to occur around the harving event
maybe that preh harving retrace gets us
to 33k in the end does it deviate just a
little bit below 33k generally speaking
a very pivotal reference point for Price
historically speaking that's the level
that needs to turn into a new support
and that's the level that will probably
springboard price into parabolic
continuation after the harving to reach
new alltime highs 200 days after the
harving event itself thank you so much
for watching today subscribe to the
channel for more videos like this in the
future like this video If you enjoyed
this one and of course check out the top
right hand corner video for more um Rec
capital and I'll speak to you in the
next one speak to you soon